[Music]  katy perry has the best response to ryan  phillippe dating rumors if you saw the  feeling that's going on inside of me you  would be like what Ryan took to Twitter  on Sunday to set the record straight on  romance rumors with the popstar the  actor tweeted I am NOT dating katy perry  barely know her please stop flying  helicopters over my house she is not  here the fact that it gets better and  better one user replied to ryan saying  that's what someone who has katy perry  in his basement would say prompting this  perfect response from the Roar singer  quote can you let me out of this  basement please to which he replied  never what a fantastic surprise Perry  ended the pair's hilarious exchange with  an apology writing nice to meet you  sorry about that ryan phillippe carry on  [Music]  you